soir soir je faisais une petite sieste
là j'étais en train de lire un texte
alors j'ai quand même l'attention de de
vous lire sérieusement après tout je
vais faire ça alors à un virus est un
programme capable de modifier d'autres
programmes en iroko payante ou partie de
son propre programme
un tel programme et auteur aux
producteurs il est également la plupart
des cas auto modifiant cette propriété
et cette propriété inhabituel de
taureaux production des programmes de
virus et est grave
dangereuse et est nuisible car bien
entendu
rares sont les programmes de virus qui
ceux qui se contentent de cet âge de
reproduction
il possède en plus dans la plupart des
cas une tâche de de destruction pouvant
aller du quart ac kaka du caractère face
alors à la modification aux malades
destruction des informations contenues
dans les mémoires de masse des
disquettes à des taureaux à la
détérioration de layton
bien bien bien bien qu'encore triki
canadienne de définition david à virus
soit à un programme capable de se
reposer d'autres programmes la la la la
la la tâche d'aider des studios des
dettes nettes ont qu à plus de cet
ouvrage qu'avocat virus passe at il une
redite de deux des stups destruction
nous ne nous attachons aux thermes terme
destruction true blood est destiné à
faire à peu près de 9 ha ha congo dont
l'exécution dans le pro ben keough au
sens où nous l'entendons en hd même si
le programme d'anti contaminé continue
de 2,2 le feu lors alors la sq a
programmé un huitième album baptisé par
l'action de david ont dit qu'is québec
qui qui qui qui dès qu'il est infecté ou
coco concocte des prêts à sylvain va
pousser des ailes les mêmes parce
qu'avec ce qu'il y ait deux virus qui la
lance cultures propres affectés sur la
coco quotas d'émission sceqe la pâte
il n'est pas seul à propos de la
démission de vote
en fait c'est un système gsm gsm chinois
l'a révélé
nolwenn leroy et christophe maé
il se bat en brèche le papa de papa
maman il ne manque pas un vain le web
[Musique]
belote
cache pas
malgré ce mauvais travail que cette
bombe à leur longue date
brazey legnano l'eau
que chaque prime
ce sport
je serai
que c'est vrai que sur noir
quelle marque
[Musique]
mais les loups ne se soit
le moment rien c'est qu'elle sait du
mort
duchaussoy
j'essaie de bahreïn
pas mal
mauvaise idée
[Musique]
je sais pas qui ne se croisent
le choix
m
je
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu